The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture today
is on the one hand,
deceptively simple, and on the
other hand, deceptively hard.
That from a certain
point of view,
to talk about the equations
of lines and planes
is, first of all, a
topic that many people
say, "I'm not interested
in studying geometry.
When are we going to
get back to calculus?"
And this is very analogous
to our problem of part one
in calculus, if
you recall, where
we started with
analytic geometry,
and the question
came up, why do we
need geometry when what
we really wanted to study
was calculus?
And the idea of graphs
played a very important role
in calculus.
We found out, for example, also,
that the relatively harmless
straight line was a
rather crucial curve.
Namely, given any curve, no
matter how random in the plane,
provided only that
it was smooth,
we were able to
approximate that curve
by a sequence of tangent
lines to various points.
And in a similar way,
one finds that planes
will do for functions of
two real variables what
the equations of lines
did for functions
of a single real variable.
As I say, we'll talk about that
in more detail as we go along.
The other nice part
about this lesson
is the fact that we can now take
some of our vector properties
that we've learned
from the past lessons
and hit what I call
the home run ball, once
and for all now, finish
off what we've started.
And that is, in the study of
three-dimensional geometry,
the crucial characteristics
are those building blocks
called lines and planes.
And by finding
convenient recipes
for expressing lines
and planes, we'll
be most of the way
home as far as using
this material is concerned.
Again, we'll hit mainly
the highlights today.
The remainder of the
material will be covered,
I hope, adequately between
the text and the exercises.
At any rate then,
the lesson today
is "Equations of
Lines and Planes."
And to refresh what I just
said before, the little ratio--
planes are to surfaces what
lines are to curves-- that we
can approximate curves
by tangent lines,
we can approximate smooth
surfaces by tangent planes.
Now what we would
like to do is go back
to Cartesian coordinates and
find the equation of a plane.
The first question that
we asked before we even
use any coordinate system is
just how much information do
you need before you
can determine a plane?
Well one way we know of is to
know three points in the plane.
Another way is analogous
to the line case,
where to determine a line, you
needed a point and a slope.
One way of determining
a plane is to know what?
A point in the plane and
the direction of the plane.
And one way of getting
the direction of the plane
is to fix a normal, a
perpendicular to the plane.
In other words, the approach
that we're going to use
is, let's suppose that
we know a point that we
want to be in our plane.
And we'll call that point P_0.
We'll denote it generically
by (x_0, y_0, z_0).
And let's let capital N denote
the vector A*i plus B*j plus
C*k, which is
perpendicular to our plane.
OK?
So we're given a vector
perpendicular to the plane,
we're given a
point in the plane,
and now in Cartesian
coordinates,
we would like to know the
equation of the plane.
And as we do so often, we simply
come back to our little diagram
here that will utilize
vector geometry.
What we say is, OK, here's
a little diagram here.
Here's P_0 in the plane.
Here's N, normal to the plane.
Now we pick any
point P whatsoever,
any point in the whole
world whatsoever, as long
as it's in space,
three-dimensional space.
And what we say is-- what
does it mean for the point P
to be in the plane?
Well, in vector language, for
the point P to be in the plane,
I think it's rather obvious
that P_0 P had better
be perpendicular to
N. On the other hand,
in dot product
language, what does it
mean to say that N is
perpendicular to P_0 P?
That says that the dot product
of N and P_0 P must be 0.
Now just to economize space,
let me utilize the notation
that we've talked
about in the notes
and in the exercises where
in Cartesian coordinates
I'll abbreviate a vector
in i, j, and k components
just by writing
down its components.
In other words, let me
abbreviate N by A comma B comma
C, which stands for A*i plus
B*j plus C*k, et cetera.
Notice the beauty, now, of our
Cartesian coordinate system.
N is the vector whose components
are A, B, and C. What about P_0
P?
Well, that's the
vector whose components
are x minus x_0, y minus
y_0, and z minus z_0,
that beauty of Cartesian
coordinates again.
Consequently, I want the dot
product of these two vectors
to be 0.
But in Cartesian
coordinates, we know
that to dot two
vectors, we simply
multiply corresponding
components and add,
and that results in what?
A times (x minus x_0) plus
B times (y minus y_0),
plus C times (z
minus z_0) equals 0.
By the way, each of these
steps is reversible,
meaning that under these given
conditions, the point (x, y, z)
is in the given
plane if and only
if this equation
here is satisfied.
Another way of
saying that is what?
If A, B, C, x_0, y_0, and
z_0 are given constants,
then A times x minus x_0 plus B
times y minus y_0 plus C times
z minus z_0 equals 0 is the
equation of the plane which
passes through the
point x_0, y_0, z_0,
and which has the vector A*i
plus B*j plus C*k as its normal
vector.
And perhaps the easiest
way to illustrate this
is again, by means
of an example.
Let me simply write down
a linear expression.
I'll write down 2 times x
minus 1 plus 3 times y plus 2
plus 4 times z minus 5.
My claim is that this is
the special case where
A, B, and C are played by
2, 3, and 4, respectively;
x_0, y_0, and z_0 are played by
1, negative 2, and negative 5--
the same thing as in
our previous study
of ordinary
two-dimensional geometry.
Remember that the standard
form of our equation
uses a minus sign.
Consequently, to
use the equation,
where we see y plus 2,
we should rewrite that
as y minus minus 2.
And what we're saying is that
this equation is then what?
It passes through
the point (1, -2, 5).
And has as its normal the
vector 2*i plus 3*j plus 4*k.
Actually, this is not a
very difficult concept
once you try a few examples and
see what's happening over here.
By the way, before
I go on, I just
want to make a note that I'm
going to return to later on.
Notice, by the way,
there is nothing
sacred about the right-hand
side of this equation being 0.
Notice that somehow or other,
the really important factor
was 2x plus 3y plus 4z.
In other words, notice that the
other terms led to a constant
which could have been transposed
onto the right-hand side
of the equation, and
that somehow or other,
I can change the constant.
But if these multipliers in
front-- the 2, 3, and 4--
stay the same, see?
Notice what I'm driving at here.
No matter how I-- let me go
back up here for a second.
No matter how I change x_0, y_0,
z_0, whatever plane this is,
it still has A*i plus B*j
plus C*k as a normal vector.
What I can change is what
point the plane passes through.
In other words, somehow or other
if I leave A, B, and C fixed,
but I vary x_0,
y_0, z_0, I generate
a family of parallel planes.
And that can be restated
somewhat differently.
Well I guess if it wasn't
somewhat differently,
that wouldn't be called
"restated," would it?
Let's just note this way.
For fixed A, B, and C, the
equation A*x plus B*y plus C*z
equals D. See, forget about
the 0 on the right-hand side.
Let D be an arbitrary constant.
What I'm saying is
that this equation
is a family of parallel planes.
And why is it a family
of parallel planes?
Because every plane in this
family has, as a normal vector,
A*i plus B*j plus C*k.
OK?
The second point I
would like to emphasize
about the equation
of our plane is
that it's called a linear
equation, meaning--
and I don't know why I suddenly
switched to small letters here,
but that certainly doesn't
make any difference.
With a, b, c, and
d as constants,
observe that a*x plus b*y plus
c*z equals d is what we call
a linear algebraic equation
in the variables x, y, and z.
Namely, each variable appears
multiplied only by a constant.
And we add these things up.
And notice that in a way,
a plane should be linear,
meaning there's no
curvature to a plane
once it's fixed in space.
And this sort of generalizes
the idea of the line.
Remember, the general definition
of a line was of the form what?
a*x plus b*y equals a constant.
That was a two-dimensional
linear equation.
The plane is a three-dimensional
And one of the
subjects that we'll
return to later in the
course, but I just mention it
in passing now, is
that even though you
can't draw in more than
three-dimensional space,
if you have 15 variables,
you can certainly
have a linear equation
in 15 unknowns.
And the interesting point in
calculus of several variables
is that even when you run out of
pictures-- when you can't draw
the situation--
the linear equation
plays a very, very special role
in the development of calculus
of several variables,
analogous to what a line does
for a curve in the
case of one variable
and what a plane
does for a surface
in the case of two variables.
What I wanted to
emphasize though, also--
and we'll come back to
this in very short order--
is that a plane has
two degrees of freedom.
Meaning what?
That in a plane, observe that
given the linear equation,
you have what?
One linear equation
and three unknowns.
It requires that you
pick two of the variables
before the rest of the
equation is determined.
In other words, if given
x + 2y + 3z = 6, if I say,
let x be 15, notice
that I have what?
15 + 2y + 3z = 6, which gives
me one equation and the two
unknowns y and z.
That to actually
uniquely fix anything,
I must specify what two of
the three variables are.
In other words,
in this equation,
I can choose any two of the
three variables at random,
and solve for the third.
By the way, if anybody
is having difficulty
understanding the
difference between the 6
being on the right-hand
side as we have it now
and the 0 as we
used it originally,
notice that we can very
quickly find a point which
this plane passes through.
For example, among
other things, just set y
and z equal to 0, in
which case x is 6.
So certainly one point in
this plane is (6, 0, 0).
What is a vector
perpendicular to this plane?
It's the vector 1i
plus 2j plus 3k.
So using the standard
form, we could write what?
x minus 6 plus 2 times y
minus 0 plus 3 times z minus 0
equals 0.
Notice, by the way,
that algebraically,
these two equations
are equivalent.
But that in this form,
this tells me what?
This specifies a point that
the plane passes through,
namely what?
This is the plane that
passes through (6, 0, 0),
and has the vector i plus
2j plus 3k as a normal.
By the way, you could do
this in different ways.
Some person might
say, why couldn't you
have transposed the 6 over
here, then taken 3z minus 6?
You see?
Why don't you let x and y be
0 and solve this equation,
and get that z equals 2?
In other words, isn't (0, 0,
2) also a point in the plane?
And the answer is, yes it is.
And you could have written
the equation now as what?
x minus 0 plus twice y minus
0 plus 3 times z minus 2
equals 0.
That would be what?
The equation of the plane
that passed through (0, 0, 2),
and had as its normal
i plus 2j plus 3k.
Of course what happens is
that (6, 0, 0) and (0, 0, 2)
belong to the same plane.
I mean, that's another
thing to keep in mind here,
that the plane that
we're talking about
passes through more
than one point.
So x_0, y_0, z_0 can be played
by an infinity of choices.
At any rate, let's
let that go now
as the equation of our
plane, and let's talk now
about the equation of a line.
That's a plane.
Let's talk about the
equation of a line.
How do we determine a line?
In two-dimensional
space, we said
we needed to know a point
on the line and the slope.
And another way
of saying that is,
we need to know a
point on the line
and we would like to know a
line parallel to the given line.
In vector language,
what we say is, OK,
let's suppose we're
given the line l.
And we know that the
vector V, whose components
are A, B, and C, that that
vector is parallel to l
and that the point P_0
whose coordinates are
(x_0, y_0, z_0), that that
point is on the line l.
Then the question is, how do we
find the equation of the line
l?
And again, vector methods
come to our aid very nicely.
What we say is, let's pick
any other point P in space.
All right?
What does it mean if the
point P is on the line l?
If the point P is on
the line l, since we
want to use vector
methods, let's
simply observe that
since l is parallel to V,
the vector P_0 P,
being parallel to V,
must be a scalar
multiple of V. That's
what parallel means for
vectors, scalar multiple.
So P_0 p is equal to
some constant times V.
And let me pause
here for a moment
to point out that this
constant is really a variable.
That sounds awful.
How can a constant
be a variable?
What I mean of course, is that
P was any point in this line.
Notice that t determines
the length of P_0 P,
and how long P_0 P is, is going
to depend on where I choose
P. In other words, for
different choices of P,
I get a different
scalar multiple.
And by the way, if I choose
P on the wrong side of P_0,
as I've deliberately
done over here,
notice that P_0 P has
the opposite sense of V.
So that t can even be negative.
In other words, not only is t a
variable, but if it's negative,
it means that P_0 P has
the opposite sense of V.
If it's positive, they
have the same sense.
But I'm not going to
belabor that point.
What I'm now going to do is,
in Cartesian coordinates,
see what this equation tells me.
And right away,
it tells me what?
That P_0 P is that vector whose
components are x minus x_0, y
minus y_0, and z minus z_0.
What vector is t times V?
Well, V, we saw, had as
components, A, B, and C.
And in Cartesian coordinates,
multiplying a vector
by a scalar simply multiplies
each component by that scalar.
So in other words, t times V is
the vector whose components are
t*A, t*B, and t*C.
We also know, in
Cartesian coordinates,
that the only way that
two vectors can be equal
is component by component.
And that tells us what?
That x minus x_0
must equal t times
A. y minus y_0 must
equal t times B.
And z minus z_0 must
equal t times C. That's
these three equations here.
What do all of these
three equations
have in common numerically?
They all have the factor t.
And consequently, I can solve
each of these three equations
for t.
Namely, what?
Divide both sides of
this equation by A,
both sides of this equation by
B, both sides of this equation
by C, being very careful that
neither A, B, nor C are 0.
By the way, if they are 0,
straightforward ramifications
take place that we'll leave
for the textbook to explain.
Don't worry about
that part right now.
We don't want to get
bogged down in that.
But at any rate, if
we now go from here
to see what that
says, we now wind up
with the standard equation
of the straight line.
Namely, if you have x minus
x_0 over A equals y minus y_0
over B equals z minus z_0
over C equals some constant t,
that particular form is
called the standard equation
for a straight line.
What straight line is it?
It's the line which passes
through the point (x_0, y_0,
z_0) and is parallel to the
vector A*i plus B*j plus C*k.
By means of an example,
x minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3
equals z minus 6 over 7
is the equation-- it's
one equation, really.
It's the equation of a line
which has what property?
It passes through
the point (1, 5, 6).
And it's parallel to the
vector 4i plus 3j plus 7k.
And by the way, I have to be
very, very on my guard here.
There's something
very deceptive here.
The equation of a
plane and a line
are very, very much different.
But they look enough alike
so it may confuse you.
You know, it reminds
me of my daughter,
who I get a lot of stories from,
was eating a sandwich one day.
And I asked her what kind of
a sandwich she was eating.
And she said it was like
a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich.
And I never heard of a sandwich
that was like a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich.
So I looked at it to see what it
was, and it was ham and cheese.
And I say, why did you say
it was like peanut butter
and jelly?
And she says well, it
was two things in it.
All right?
Lookit.
The equation of a
line and the plane
have three things
in it-- x, y, and z.
But to juxtaposition these,
let me write down the two
things that may look confusing.
Let's suppose I write this down.
You see what I'm doing now?
What I'm doing now is I'm
changing the equal signs here
to plus signs and bringing
up the denominators here.
See, this is a line.
This is a plane.
What plane is this?
This is the plane which passes
through the point 1 comma
5, comma 6, and has the line of
the vector 4i plus 3j plus 7k
as its normal.
How can I best
explain this to you
to keep this straight
in your mind?
Well, I think the
easiest way-- and again,
notice what I'm
saying, see the x,
y's, and z's here, the
x, y's and z's here.
Which is which?
The easiest way is to keep
track of degrees of freedom.
Remember in the
plane, we said lookit.
You can pick two of
the variables at random
and solve for the third.
I claim in this system--
in this system here,
there is only one
degree of freedom.
The line has one
Namely, let's
repeat this example,
so we don't have to keep
looking back to the board here.
Let's take x minus 1 over
4 equals y minus 5 over 3
equals z minus 6 over 7.
And since we don't like
to work with fractions,
I'll pick a number
that works out nicely.
I say, OK, let's see
what happens when x is 9.
Now here's the whole point.
As soon as I say that x equals
9, as soon as I let x equal 9,
this is fixed.
Right?
In fact, what does it become
fixed as soon as I do this?
As soon as x equals 9,
x minus 1 over 4 is 2.
Now notice that y minus
5 over 3 has to equal 2.
Well I have no more choice then.
If y minus 5 over 3 has to equal
2, and also z minus 6 over 7
has to equal 2-- you see
what I'm saying here?
This fixes the fact that y must
be 11, and that z must be 20.
In other words, the
choice of x equals
9 forces me to make y
equal 11 and z equal 20.
One degree of freedom.
And by the way, if you
want to see this thing
from a geometrical point
of view, what we're saying
is, visualize this line cutting
through space, all right?
Notice that directly
on that line,
only one point will have
its x-coordinate equal to 9.
And what we're
saying is, the point
on that line whose
x-coordinate is 9
is the point 9
comma 11 comma 20.
OK?
One degree of freedom again.
That's very, very
crucial for you to see.
By the way, I guess one thing
that bothers a lot of students
is the fact that they read
this as two separate equations.
They say, you know, why
isn't this x minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3?
Why can't I treat
that as one equation?
Or why couldn't I take y minus 5
over 3 equals z minus 6 over 7?
Or why couldn't I
take x minus 1 over 4
and say that equals
z minus 6 over 7?
And the answer is, that
by itself isn't enough.
But rather than give
you a negative answer,
let me give you a positive one.
Let me close today's lesson with
this particular illustration.
Suppose we had solved x minus 1
over 4 equals y minus 5 over 3.
What we would have
obtained is the equation
4y minus 3x equals 17.
Now this is very dangerous.
When you look at the equation
4y minus 3x equals 17,
I'll bet you
dollars to doughnuts
you tend to think of this as
a line rather than as a plane.
But the interesting
thing is, notice
that the way we
got this equation
was ignoring the
z-coordinate of our points.
And what we're really
saying is, let's forget
about the z-coordinate.
In other words,
4y minus 3x equals
17 may be viewed as a line,
but in this particular case,
it's a plane.
In fact, what plane is it?
It's the plane that goes
through the line 4y minus 3x
equals 17, which
lies on the xy-plane.
It's the plane that goes
through that line perpendicular
to the xy-plane.
By the way, again, if you go
back to part one of this course
where we stress sets,
the language of sets
comes to our rescue very nicely.
The difference between
whether 4y minus 3x equals
17 is a plane or
whether it's a line
hinges on whether we're
talking about the set of pairs
x comma y such that
4y minus 3x equals 17,
or whether we're talking about
the set of triplets (x, y, z)
such that 4y minus 3x equals 17.
In this particular
example, we're
talking about points in space.
In other words, our
universe of discourse
are the points x comma y comma
z, not the points x comma y.
Well anyway, rather than
to belabor this point, what
I'm saying is, in the same way
that this equation represents
a plane, in a similar way, had
we equated y minus 5 over 3
equals z minus 6
over 7, we would've
obtained the plane 7y
minus 3z equals 17.
So if you don't like to look
at our set of three equations,
if you'd like to look
at these three equations
in pairs-- you see, if you
want to look at these three
equations in pairs,
another way of saying
it is this, that the triple
equality-- x minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3
equals z minus 6 over 7--
that that may be viewed as
the intersection of the two
planes-- namely the plane
determined by this equation
and the plane determined
by this equation.
Of course, someone can also
say, isn't there a plane
determined by this
one and this one?
And the answer is yes, there is.
Notice that whereas you
have three equalities here,
only two of them
are independent.
Namely, as soon as
the first equals
the second and the
second equals the third,
the first must equal the third.
OK?
But the whole idea is, can
you now see the difference?
The easiest way I
know of to distinguish
the difference between the
equation of a line and a plane.
The plane has two
degrees of freedom.
The line has but one
degree of freedom.
And that triple equality
says as soon as you've
picked one of the
unknowns, you've
determined all of the others.
Whereas that string
of plus signs
says that once you've
determined one,
you still have
some freedom left.
Now what we're going
to do is next time
start a new phase of vectors.
For the time being,
what we have now done
is finished, at
least for the moment,
our preliminary investigation
of three-dimensional space
as seen through the eyes
of Cartesian coordinates.
At any rate, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.